hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from the seventh leaches
titled arena it's again between worlds
champion Magnus Carlsen who played under
the handle GM man with a van now I have
no idea I've heard some stories on the
internet that he was actually playing
from a van via a mobile device such as a
tablet or a smartphone now well this
this may or may not be true it's still a
very nice game and still a very nice
story so I decided to share it he's
playing against 19 year old American
chess prodigy
Akshay Chandra also known as Bubba a
grandmaster Baba Ramdev unleashes and
it's really a nice game okay you might
argue that it's silly showing a bullet
game but to me it's extremely
interesting how really strong
grandmasters make very principled
decisions in such you know a lot of low
time controls so it's very interesting
also how cross and every time he plays
in delete chess titled arena he always
applies we are his real handle either
magnus carlsen or dr. frankenstein but
then when the tournament actually starts
his real handle just disappears and then
everyone tries to figure out under which
handle he is currently playing so this
time it was a grandmaster a man with a
with a van and it I I have I kind of
have a question for you do you think he
would score a better result if everyone
knew they were playing against Magnus
Carlsen or would he perhaps score a
better result in a tournament when no
one has an idea that they were actually
playing against the world champion so
what did they like be nervous if they
knew they were playing against Carson
and then blunder more often or you know
make poor moves or would they like try
real hard and really concentrate to try
and beat a world champion which brings
me to this very interesting tweet by
international master Eric Rosen he
tweeted that it's been on his bucket
list for a while to play Magnus Carlsen
in chess and he says that today he
unknowingly played him in the leisure
styled arena and won there we have it
international master Eric Rosen a
victory against the GM man with a van so
it's a very interesting
is it better for Carlson to play under
under his real handle or under a
different handle every time but okay
that being said you know feel free to
share your thoughts in the comments
let's check out this very nice game
cross and opens with E 4 we have e 6 the
French defense Knight c3 B 5 B 4 now and
the Knight to f6 transposing into the
classical variation he captures it
captures we have the exchange variation
and Bishop to g5 Bishop to d6 we have
Queen d2 c6 Carson castles Queen side
and Chandra castles King side so we have
opposite castles and there will
definitely be an attack on both sides of
the board Bishop to d3 eyeing that h7
pawn Knight bb7
+ f3 now controlling this night
not allowing any squares for him how
about also preparing g4 h 4 and so on
and so on
Queen to c7 and he will have night the g
- e - of course the black will never
capture for example upon like this this
only opens up the H file for white but
not only that in this instance it will
lose by force after Bishop to h6 you're
now threatening Queen to g5 and pretty
much whatever you do if you go back you
get Bishop captures and g7 even even
this keen captures you can go Queen g5
check King h8 and now mercial captures
on h7 would be sufficient now it
captures rook captures and everything
would would fall in place here after g3
there's no defense against rook captures
h2 and checkmate
so after Knight G to b5 now Chandra
simply starts off a Queen side attack we
have G for
Carlsen starts pushing on the Kings side
we have before and now Knight to B 1 a 5
with Knight to g3 and now a for Knight
to f5 cross then has to move the knight
to either exchange it for a bishop here
or - you know increased pressure on the
King side but also while the knight is
in g3 you can't really push th pawn as
black would simply capture this night so
kb3 a capture some b3 a capture some b3
and now it seems like
c3 would be
a better move then what girl simply but
it's really not even though this seems
like a very strong structure c5 really
tears it apart so cross and simply
captures the pawn here see capture some
b3 and do not rope to a 1 a very nice
active move controlling the night and
preparing to continue the attacks on the
Queen side rook H 2 e 1 by Carlson and
ok c5 we have nice captures on d6 cross
and illuminates this Bishop and now we
have Queen captures on d6 and ok
although this is a pre moved capture
since it's a bullet game but for some
some of you who are perhaps new to chess
there there's something inches that's
called a and autumn automatic recaptures
sometimes your opponent will capture
something like we had here tonight
captures Bishop and then your first
inclination would be to recapture the
night immediately well there is a better
move in the position which is C captures
on d4 a nice situation to Lauren in
between move first you give you give a
little check and after white deals with
this check now you can either capture or
recapture the knight or simply continue
the attack night to c5 here the thread
is of course Knight captures b3 with
checkmate as the bishop and c2 is pinned
and after white deals with this let's
say Queen to before there's d3 so a lot
of a lot of interesting ideas here of
course if you capture the bishop is
still pinned you're losing the Queen
here so just you know putting it out
there never do an automatic to recapture
okay Queen captures on d6 and now we
have Queen to f4 Carlsen once the trade
Queen's as his King is very exposed on
c1 Queen c6 we have King to d2 you have
to run away
rook to a2 and now D captures on c5 rook
after some b2 with check and here
Carlson plays King to c3 he attacks the
rook with his King rook to a 2 and now
comes the Queen to d6 again the cross
and offers the trade of Queens and here
a queen trade would definitely relieved
a lot of pressure for white so black
finds a nice way to continue the attack
d4 this is the strongest move you check
the King and also now the queen is able
to capture on f3 and here you definitely
have to capture on d4 but
to make such a decision in a bullet game
as quite admirable as you know you're
bringing your king to d4 but okay
let's say if white tries something like
Queen to b4 then Queen to a it is very
dangerous the queen is coming to a5 and
after you play anything let's say Bishop
captures then you get Queen to a5 King
moves now comes Knight recaptures and
you will once again have to go for
example to d4 and then rook to d8 will
pick up the Queen and black wins here so
after d4 check we have King captures on
d4 by Carlsen Queen captures on f3 and
now Bishop captures on f6 Knight
captures on f6 and now g5 Crossan
continues attacking he wants to displace
this night from f6 and you know pretends
like his king even isn't even on d4
Queen g4 check King moves and now Queen
captures on g5 so Chandra gets rid of
that pawn he keeps his knight on f6 and
now we have rook to e5 a nice rook lift
with a temple on the Queen preparing a
doubling of the rooks and the e-file
Queen to f4 rook to e1 and now Queen
captures on h2 with some ideas of
perhaps coming to the b2 with check so
Carlsen first move the King King before
we have Queen to f4 check and now Bishop
to c4 and here it's it's very black is
better here but it's also not that easy
to play this for black for example if
you're not careful if you move the
knight let's say Knight to g4 do you see
how white can win instantly here I feel
free to pause the video and try to find
there is a very nice idea I'll give you
a couple of seconds if you want to
decide whether to do it or not so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
checkmater in - and for those who just
wanna enjoy the show Queen captures on
f8 of course is the idea only move King
captures and now rook to e8 will be
checkmate it's okay
Bishop to c4 and now Bishop to a6
we have Knight to c3 the strongest move
and it doesn't really make all that much
sense to move the rook although you can
do it for example Roxy - but then Knight
to e4 is coming you want to remove this
night from f6 and then
the position will be much better for
white so let's say 97 you offer the
Knights to capture the rook but then
comes rook to e8 and now you offer the
Queen here Queen captures Knight
captures on d6 sorry Queen captures
Knight captures Bishop captures on c4
and after Knight captures on c4 our
black is up a pawn but White has this
very strong passed pawn also a nice fast
born so white would be of course better
here it's okay Knight c3 we have better
ship captures Knight captures on a to
cross and wins the exchange here and now
Bishop back to e6 and it's a very nice
capture because you have to see while
being only seconds down on the clock
that there's no actual good discovery
with the bishop but all of the pieces
are on dark squares so hopefully there
isn't no no good discoveries for black
Bishop e6 we would have discovered to
check King to a3 and now rook to e8 with
check King Tubby to and now Queen to
have to go to check rook one to e2
blocking Queen to f3 and now comes Luke
captures on e6 Carson doesn't bother
with Knight to c3 although it is the
best move you don't want to allow black
any chances so it's with only seconds
and the clock it's better to simply
capture the bishop remove the threat of
Queen captures and b3f captures and now
Queen captures on e6 with check King to
h8 and only now nice to see three so
here the material on the board is
completely equal but again cousin has a
very strong passed pawn and it will be
very hard to stop it especially with
seconds on the clock
h6 we have c6 and here you should simply
continue for example with h5 or
something try and try and push but here
chandra plays Knight to g4 and here the
position is completely lost for black
after c7 now the black Queen can't help
out with the defense of the back rank
because she's stuck defending the knight
and g4
so an unfortunate blunder but you know
it's bullet King h7 we have c8 cross and
brings another Queen into the game
captures captures a nice to f6 Queen to
e6 and now and I air Queen to g4 we have
before
these are all now
three moves as you know they have very
little time on the clock but the
position is winning for white so it
doesn't really matter although black
black can even capture upon here but
black also pre moved queen g6 I will
have B 5 H 6 and now Queen to b3 with
only seconds on the clock across and
finds that this combined with c2 will be
the easiest way to exchange Queens and
then he will be able to push his pawn to
victory 94 we have Queen c2 King H 6
captures captures now b6 Knight to f6
the knight isn't time to stop the point
from promotion we have b7 night here and
now rook to d1 Knight b8 we have rook
check King moves and now Knight to d5
and knife to a 6 here Carson doesn't
even capture it as he probably pre moved
Knight to f4 now but it doesn't matter
as there was no time on the clock left
for Bubba random or a grand master
Archer Chandra and here he was the game
on time but yeah I mean such an eventful
fight and a 55 moves played with only 1
minute per player I think it was a very
nice game and even though it's a board
game I think it was worth showing if for
nothing for who for entertainment
purposes so yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it and here we have the
standings of the seventhly chess titled
arena the the tournament was won by
international master mud bro who is an
interim an international master from
vietnam called min lee second place was
grandmaster Zalman chess mood who not
sure who he was but he does have in the
description of his profile that he was a
former Junior World Chess Champion from
Armenia so definitely he is Alvin
andreasson from Armenia he says that the
only way to really learn chess well is
to get in in the mood for chest so
probably that's why the nickname is Azam
in chess mode and in third place
Grandmaster man man with a van or Magnus
Carlsen and then we have Grandmaster
Rebecca Harris that's the owner did say
I believe then urgh Meier international
master
dark ghoul then International Master
Shrek davit then feed a master nice
grandmaster retired 93 don't know who
that is and in tenth place Grandmaster
Baba Ramdev who you already saw in this
game so that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank our
mottos dog Julien Sean John Abraham Gary
Ren and Benjamin tolerant for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
think all for watching and don't forget
to try and answer the question I asked
in the beginning of the video now do you
think Carson's result would be better in
a tournament if everyone knew who he was
or if he was anonymous and until the end
of the tournament so thank you all and
I'll see you soon I'll most likely
continuing the Bobby Fischer series